where do you have his speech yeah you
want the transcript or you want the
audio read some of the transcripts okay
I'll start at the beginning
god I'm full of so much gratitude right
now and I do not feel elevated above any
of my fellow nominees or anyone in this
room because we share the same love the
love of film lie I'm it's a lie I just
want a thing I don't feel elevated how
not you won this is this is the problem
people can tell these people are full of
[ __ ] immediately
I don't feel elevated know the people
that aren't elevated or in their seats
you've been elevated you don't it
doesn't matter how you feel it's again
the feeling stuff and this form of
expression has given me the most
extraordinary life I don't know what I'd
be without it but I know I've got a
pretty good idea of what you'd be you'd
be in a bar you know somewhere getting
hammered yeah I have a good idea
Joaquin of where you'd be then I'm good
but I think the greatest gift that has
given me oh I think the greatest gift
that it's given me and many of us in
this room is the opportunity to use our
voice for the voiceless right yeah and
and we say who they are and we choose or
the voiceless how great is that
how great is calling large swathes of
the American public voiceless they have
voices they're using them all the time
on things you then you shut them down on
social media they use their voice and
you go you're a Nazi and you take their
account away half the time a voice with
a voiceless
who are these voiceless people oh I'm
inundated with all day's people's voices
Facebook Twitter Instagram everybody
nobody shuts the [ __ ] up there's nobody
in this country without a voice unless
they literally don't have a voice unless
they literally had their throat removed
with cancer there's nobody that doesn't
have a voice in fact I think people's
voices are a little too loud the
voiceless that [ __ ] might have worked 10
years ago there's no one who's voiceless
anymore Bill Cosby's tweeting from a
prison cell at Snoop Dogg who is voice
and I mean look and I know that he's
using it as like you know an expression
to mean people that don't have the
political power and economic
power that he does but words mean things
and when you start saying that people
are voiceless and that you need to speak
for these voiceless people again you've
set up this entire thing that's wrong
it's completely wrong you I I I am here
to which speak of those who appointed
you to speak for the voiceless cuz you
won a trophy because you pretended to be
the Joker why ain't God why isn't it a
scientist who speaks for the voiceless
or a doctor or a philosopher why in
god's name is it you who who made you
the the [ __ ] standard bearer keep
going I've been thinking a lot about
some of the distressing issues that we
are facing collectively oh good
that's when you're watching you're like
oh good I think at times we feel or were
made to use how much here's how good he
was a joker this is how good of an actor
he is I know that's not true I know that
you're not spending a ton of time
thinking about these issues because you
did a phenomenal job in that [ __ ]
movie and you can you know Serena
Williams and veena you just can't spend
a like Serena Williams is not sitting
around thinking about trade it's not
happening
I'm telling you right now Venus Williams
whichever ones still relevant [ __ ] off I
don't care no it's the other one shut up
they're both fine the point is this I'll
be both of them I was at as my
grandfather used to I used to play
tennis in mutton town Long Island
perhaps you've heard of it
he had a tennis court on his property
okay and I would play tennis too okay in
a in a classy way I think at times we
feel or were made to feel that we
champion different causes but for me I
see commonality I think whether we're
talking about gender inequality or
racism or queer rights or indigenous
rights or animal rights we're talking
about the fight against injustice we're
talking about the fight against the
belief that one nation one people one
race one gender or one species whatever
is the dominant control and use and
exploit another with impunity
I think we've become very disconnected
from the natural world and many of us
what guilty hey Joaquin
guess who's guess who's suspect number
one who's been a little disconnected
from the natural world
now I was gonna talk by the way this
flows in this is what I love they
disconnected from the natural world will
now flow into how no one supposed to eat
animals what have you ever seen have you
watched any nature documentary ever any
show ever on nature nobody in the
natural world is handing each other
trophies there's no bear getting up at a
podium and going I am a voice for the
voiceless I am here to give a voice for
the pit like what are you even saying
the the beginning of that is all like
you know Bard College which is the
Columbia School for Women and I'm not
saying that it's because they're women
but Bard College freshman year paper
that was handed to him before he got on
stage continued we go as many great
women that are very smart in this
country by the way I'm gonna name five
Barbara Bush because she knew her
husband was involved in JFK
assassination she helped cover it up I
will tell you why that's great it's
great dig she's a very smart woman Tana
[ __ ] Mogo she's an Instagram influencer
from Las Vegas who married Jake Paul and
a fake wedding and I'm a fan of her I
don't know why but I stand her I don't
know why I like her she's got the big
tits to fake face to fake lips but
there's something about her I like is
something I like people that come out of
Vegas it just seems like everyone born
in Vegas should die so what someone
makes it out of Vegas I liked it I liked
it she's selling ass lip gloss and big
tits that's what we get so I like her so
Barbara Bush Tana um I don't know anyone
else now and I can't I can't do the
whole episode I can't I can't it's gonna
take me 40 minutes a day you're gonna
say Michelle Carter at some point no
because Michelle Carter just got lucky
yeah she just got lucky she was a
devious [ __ ] who told her boyfriend to
get back into that car and after that
documentary I was over him but I was I
was over her but I was over him I'm over
him it's another good-looking guy who's
like I didn't wanna die and then she's
like die die I'm over him I'm over his
family I'm over HBO given documentaries
to this horseshit when what
some white kid gets killed shut the [ __ ]
up I mean enough already there's black
people getting shot in the CVS give them
a documentary who cares I'm sick of this
[ __ ] it's a small town
it's a everything on Netflix Nate feel
is about a small town that's being eaten
alive by something well let it get eaten
that enough sick of this [ __ ]
Michelle Carter where's my [ __ ]
special you got specials on HBO with the
trailers like I don't do stand-up I just
like driving around in a car yeah go on
what we're guilty of is an egocentric
worldview the belief that were this
center of the universe we go into the
natural world and we plunder it for its
resources we feel entitled to
artificially inseminate a cow and when
she gives birth we still her baby how
are the people how are the people in the
developing world going to eat
Joaquin without some fusion of science
and agriculture how are people in the
third world going to eat dummy they can
post mates vegan avocado toast to their
house like you probably do and some
terrified open mic comedian has to go
past your gate and and hand you
something okay Bernie Sanders should
execute all of these people and I will
support him everyone knows that I'm a
Tom Styer guy Stan's tire steyr is
starters is the candidate to win and I
only say that because I don't know who
he is and I won't know I won't know
whose tire is until I write his name in
on the ballot in 2020 but if Bernie said
here's what we gonna do we're gonna rein
in Wall Street we're gonna take all the
CEOs out and shoot him in the face and
then we're gonna go to Hollywood news
shoot them in the face and then we're
gonna give Tim Dylan a show on HBO and
not some con to convince a boyfriend to
kill himself because Tim Dylan's
actually talented stop giving murderers
all the airtime
can we stop giving murderers all the
airtime in this country now you got to
murder someone in a small town to get a
show now I'm sorry I didn't kill someone
in a small American town you know
me steven avery's had nine seasons of a
show because he's he raped and murdered
people in a town you know in a salvage
yard so he gets his show but I can't get
a show because I haven't done that I
haven't slit someone's throat with a
carburetor in Wisconsin I apologize
because everyone wants to sit around and
watch murder all day in a small town
where people go home you know I'm so
down an earthy and let's just shook up
the whole town continue I apologize and
when she gives birth we still her baby
even though her cries of anguish are
unmistakable then we take her milk these
people are all for late term abortion
they're awful late term abortion they're
like we stole the cows baby you you
don't mind if women take their baby and
throw it out of the window at
cedars-sinai because it gets in the way
of the book that they're writing again
no consistency here I would love I would
love if he got up on stage grabbed the
trophy went I love death thank you and
just walked off stage I would clap and I
go [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah consistency I
stand sire sire Stan
then we take her milk that's intense are
you in that's Tom Styer logo are you in
it's like a bunch of seventh graders
about to vandalize their gym having a
powwow are you in it's literally the
stupidest logo I've ever had but he's
for structural reform which isn't real
and doesn't it's just a coupling of
words I've always found hilarious
structural reform Oh so we're gonna it
will also reform the structure of it
good keep going I apologize then we take
her milk that's intended for her calf
and we put it in our coffee and our
cereal and I think we fear the idea of
personal change because we think that we
have to sacrifice something to give
something up but human beings at our
best are so inventive and creative and
ingenious and I think that when we use
love and compassion as our guiding
principles we can create develop and
implement systems of change that are
beneficial to all sentient beings and
the environment now I have been I have
been a scoundrel in my life
I've been selfish I've been cruel at
times hard to work with and I'm grateful
that's so now now that's all over that
I'm
they're my selfish ways are done now
that I have all the money in the world
now that I've done amassing money with
the selfishness I've decided to be a
great person
Chelsea Handler buys a house in Bel Air
calling that that tiny Mexican guy on a
show a nugget for five years and then
decides that you know she's Malcolm X
when she has a house in Bel Air
it's nobody on the journey decides
nobody has these revelations when
they're broke by the way he's not
interesting nobody has any of these
revelations and so they have a lot of
money yeah there's something about
sitting in a pool every day and watching
Netflix documentaries about murder that
makes you feel pretty damn lucky these
people go I'm pretty lucky I don't live
in Ferguson Missouri I'm pretty lucky
and then they they start telling
everybody what to do then they start
criticizing like you know oh you know we
steal the baby from the cow we steal her
baby it's it's the most insane we don't
want to give up milk in our cereal I've
been a scoundrel I'm grateful that so
many of you in this room have given me a
second chance and I think that's when
we're at our best when we support each
other and give me a that's when we're at
our best we support me we give me
another chance because I've been
horrible and abusive to people on SATs
and I'm a dick but I also am a genius
he's an amazing actor so when I treat
people like [ __ ] because I'm talented
would find there's some trade-off there
I you know I'm very happy we're our best
when we forget about the scoundrel that
I've been for my entire life and career
we're in our best that's when we're all
at our best when we support each other
not when we cancel each other out for
past mistakes but when we help each
other - right dad you know what that
means hey don't dig too deep bond go
walk in don't dig too deep on Joaquin
I'm saying no more milk I'm I'm on the
thing I've been handed bullet points by
a freshman at Columbia University to
read here at the Oscars don't go looking
back for the many moments where I was a
scoundrel let's not none of the
canceling let's start the process of
giving me more work and money because
that's when weren't our best but when we
help each other to grow when we educate
each other when we guide each other
toward redemption that is the best of
humanity when he was 17 my brother wrote
this lyric he said run to the rescue
with love and peace will follow man to
the wrong brother bite it did the wrong
brother check out huh I'd love to have
river back he'd probably be saying the
same [ __ ] but I don't know at least more
poetically